en 20 ans d'existence la géode est
devenu un lieu d'attraction populaire
c'est même la salle de cinéma la plus
fréquentée d'europe avec plus de 500
mille spectateurs parents qui viennent
découvrir des images sur écran géant
la géode entre maintenant de plain pied
dans le 21e siècle avec un nouveau
système de projection d'image numérique
que nous dévoile patrick esther à la
cité des sciences et de l'industrie
l'écran de la géode fait désormais
exploser les images numériques haute
définition en relief pas question pour
autant d'avoir donné les projections en
film en imax
c'était nickel 70 mm projeté
horizontalement une qualité remarquable
mais des bobines plutôt encombrante la
révolution elle tient dans cette
mallette façon j'aime secondes un objet
extrêmement précieux certains disques
durs informatiques que le studio nous
livre la capacité ces 90 minutes et ses
clés représente à peu près deux bobines
comme celle ci le programme numérique et
transféré sur trois serveurs
c'est à dire trois ordinateurs ceux-ci
calcul les images et pilote six énormes
vidéo projecteur hd installés 12 mètres
plus haut dans une nouvelle cabine
c'est la première fois qu'on l'a fait
aussi projecteurs et c'est la première
fois qu'on obtient une si grande image
500 m² c'est surprenant
les projecteurs sont couplés deux par
deux ce qui permet d'obtenir la vision
en relief avec une précision encore
jamais vu mais pour cela les spectateurs
doivent toujours chausser des lunettes
spéciales polarisant la lumière ce
nouveau système ne servira pas
uniquement à la projection de
documentaires ou de films d'animation en
deux ou trois dimensions réalisé en
images de synthèse
non le numérique autorisera bien
d'autres types de spectacles high tech
c'est une nouvelle programmation de
nouvelles portes qui s'ouvrent vers la
vidéotransmission vers la 3d relief vers
la captation d'événements en direct ou
en live dans la salle
en effet grâce à des récepteurs
satellite haute définition la géode peut
désormais retransmettre des concerts
classiques ou encore n'importe quel type
d'événements sportifs
mais les plus branchés apprécieront
surtout le vjing c'est à dire des
projections d'imagés créées par des
artistes numériques inspiré en direct
par un groupe de musiciens électroniques
jouant leur propre composition
non